how's it going bros my name is feedback
welcome to afraid of monsters I'm afraid
I think I might want to kill my fit
right here just do it and then it's done
no we're gonna do it the thing is I
looked up what I am gonna do and I have
to run here through this [ __ ]
corridor this is about I don't know 50
of them and oh oh [ __ ] did you see that
alright oh well I have oh oh god there's
another one or they go through
everything around through everyone get
the gun go downstairs
high five Jesus I don't know a lot of
things this is yeah not ah yeah bad foot
Oh boom up is best yeah
get to go yes yes bring it bring it but
okay front back back back
who's the [ __ ] now [ __ ]
alright let's do a [ __ ] same
now at the rundown this oh okay
bro bro bro uh oh no my flashlight oh no
it's the other thing uh ah it's so light
really it's this dark oh okay that
helped hey with a [ __ ] much oh oh oh
okay
ah [ __ ] I can't see penis
ah here's the oyster
okay I have to shoot to see this [ __ ]
ridiculous
Boop okay here's here it is left here
somewhere
oh [ __ ] I'm out of ammo I don't think I
need to go for longer save go back or
something that's just way too [ __ ]
dark alright and not waste my flashlight
like a [ __ ] all right
go okay
all right hello go go oh I want to go
all the way
give me my boat good girl uh-huh all
right get my gun
whoa no dos tres cuatro Cinco
all right
Brook ma bro bro bro
uno dos tres cuatro okay okay now if we
go downstairs downstairs down in my
pants
OOP Go Go
here's the door here's the door just go
don't come in here
throws a dart yeah all right now we need
to find a battery AIDS [ __ ] SAP all
right what is this no gum
[ __ ] you [ __ ] it huh little bugger oh
okay we're gonna have more at least
oh and here's please we're gonna go [ __ ]
I don't have a lot of batteries
batteries batteries batteries batteries
batteries batteries spiders spiders bite
right fine I'll just save here because I
don't I don't know anymore
[ __ ] this game [ __ ] this game like this
game like this game like this game ow
die die I was good this way I look
possible I'm [ __ ]
ah
how do I die by going down there I
thought I was trying to go oh no
why ah really yeah why the [ __ ] you want
me to go that year top top top top top
top top top top top top I can't do [ __ ]
I [ __ ] gay
did I not press the buff though no don't
tell me then [ __ ]
I press the bottom I swear open this
okay let's just go back
oh I don't like this Oh keep it separate
go go
[ __ ] creepy huh
okay
alright alright I don't have a
flashlight but that's cool today I
[ __ ] press it what are you alright oh
I get it maybe you go up no up is he
here I don't get it at all quite frankly
I might have [ __ ] since uh oh that's my
head that's beautiful
Oh holy [ __ ] how did I do that oh there
we go alright there's another save all
right we good we're [ __ ] good I
finally did that Allah why we going I
don't trust this place huh pipes
I like pipes man oh [ __ ] I can hear them
Wow
Oh
oh [ __ ] penis ah [ __ ] penis I'm out of
flashbang
give me battery or something pocket
guess I've to loading to be faster or
something I don't know why do I fight
flashlights anyway
[ __ ] am I
oh okay
all right again
or as I hear oh what the [ __ ] is up oh
oh
don't chase me boo oh oh oh oh no oh oh
it goes
that is stuff
I don't have any flashlights
where am i this is so dog I don't I
don't get anything I'm just so [ __ ]
into this game right now
I was flood everywhere [ __ ]
wheelchair bro not a pro oh god I'm
totally out
all right I know this is a short video
and all that I just don't understand
this mall at all it's too difficult like
if I don't have any flashlights what am
I gonna do I don't get it
I don't get it I'm just gonna go play
amnesia and hopefully someone over you
bros can give me some tips anyway I hope
you enjoy it anyway
that's pretty much it haha
you
yeah dad are we rolling sweet I'm scared
I'm to ignore a doer